early morning a leak chart Musa Adam
like his father - grandfather before him
earns a living as a fisherman for
centuries the lakes waters have been a
rich source of food and water for the
people living on its shores ten years
ago a catch as little as this would have
been thrown back but not anymore fish
are now so scarce that every single one
however tiny will be shared out in the
village each person want fish but the
problem is what happens when there are
no fish no fish means no food and no
jobs from the air the fishermen's
problem is clear to see what was once
one of the world's largest lakes is now
a patchwork of weeds ponds and islands
images from space show how a huge body
of water fifty years ago is now just a
twentieth of that size a combination of
recurrent droughts and temperatures of
up to 50 degrees Celsius is the root of
the problem the late is now just seven
meters at its deepest and land that was
once fertile has chant dusty and barren
for communities living on the lakes edge
the effects are devastating
whatever IANA first we didn't know
anything about malnutrition but now
there are huge numbers of malnourished
people the children are all malnourished
there are no more fish there's no more
milk no maize vegetables or cereal
at the nearby clinic there's further
evidence of the problem
weighing just seven kilos five-year-old
fatima is less than half the weight of a
healthy child her age back to me ODB
[ __ ] him in a parle pas la vie nifty new
pocket when fatima came here she didn't
speak she she was always lying down with
empty eyes now he's asking for water and
food to wash her or to dress her so now
we've got house parties where food has
been grown it's an irrigated field but
over use of water is also contributing
to the lakes shrinking size
at its current rate of decline the lake
could be gone within twenty years there
has even been talk of I threatened the
region's rivers to repeal it official
figures show that more than 20 million
people depend on these waters if there
are solutions we must find them for
every problem there is a solution the
lake is in the process of disappearing
and the lake feeds many people not just
here but also for people in other
countries living near the lake like
Nigeria Cameroon and new year local
community groups meanwhile are trying to
halt the erosion by planting trees along
its shores I was born here I grew up
here and I want the lake to come back
not just for me but for the children of
the future to stop the Sahara we must
put an extra effort every day and every
night we must work reforestation
programs are slow and Lake Chad is
drying up fast so far no alternative
solution can be found villages
determination at least offers hope to
the communities who call this region
their home